what do you think Verizon can do with
Yahoo that Yahoo couldn't do as an
independent company well I think that
there's tremendous scale that comes
together from all the different assets
that they've been investing in and you
know overall I think that for us one of
the big challenges we've had is we've
been reinvented our products we've tried
to make you know Yahoo Mail you know
perfect for the phone and we're very
proud of where Yahoo Mail with that
client is today same thing is true for
news for weather sports finance we've
got about eight cornerstone applications
that you know when users use them they
engage with them they love them and give
them every single day and we really need
more distribution so for us Verizon has
tremendous mobile distribution and
that's at least one area that we're very
excited about but overall I think it
represents just a huge amount of scale
and an opportunity for her Verizon
you've said you plan to stay what role
do you envision for yourself in this new
entity well I think that for the
immediate future obviously the
transaction is expected to close in q1
next year mine immediately I've got two
priorities one is seeing this
transaction through to close but also
watching over the value of our Asian
assets and the equity stakes that we
have there and then moving forward you
know we will ultimately figure it out
this process has been a little bit
different because unlike in one-on-one
acquisition where you spend a lot of
time doing the actual acquisition
process leading up to the announcement
designing the integration plans we've
been an auction process so we're going
to sit down with with Marnie and Tim and
and folks at Verizon AOL this week
really start to design some of those
integration plans but I love Yahoo and
it's really important to me to see you
into the next chapter so you came here
with so much possibility so much hope
you wanted to restore Yahoo to greatness
bring search back build-out news and
original content how do you personally
feel about this outcome I feel very good
about it I think that Yahoo is a company
that changed the world and not very many
companies get to change the world
and if you think about it before Yahoo
the internet was a government research
project really humanized the web it's
one of the reasons that
all the tab email accounts a popularized
search and real-time media and you know
and that's and that's just really
amazing and then you know to me it was
really how do we take all of those
historical moments and influences that
has had and harness that in the paradigm
shift to mobile and when you look at
where the business is today you know
we're really proud of where our products
are the way we've transitioned our users
we have more than a billion users each
month on our properties 600 million of
those are coming to us through mobile
that's tripled over the past four years
and a large part we think because of the
quality of the products the investments
that we that we've made there and so you
know to take this you know incredibly
powerful transformational company that
has changed the world and helped see it
into this new era is incredibly
important and obviously this transaction
isn't just about the strategic future
for Yahoo but it's also about unlocking
value for our shareholders in the
remaining equity stakes etc and so this
is really an opportunity to kill two
birds with one stone so to speak and you
know when we feel that we've really
achieved that with this outcome do you
think having an activist investor made
it harder made your job harder I think
that you know the company has had
various active agendas around it over
the past over the past few years and I
think that you know you should always be
open to challenge you should always be
open to scrutiny I do think that there's
certainly some elements that become more
of a distraction but the challenge in
the scrutiny isn't something that I
would shy away from I think there was a
lot I grew 'tony I think that it really
you know is something that you've got to
be able to stay focused through it and
yeah I couldn't be prouder with how the
teams have executed throughout this
process through this period of
uncertainty that's been that's been you
know that's been around the strategic
review process that we that we've been
in you know we have exceeded our goals
for the first half of the year and so we
want to keep that momentum going in the
second half of the year and into the the
operating businesses new future
what about Alibaba did Alibaba make
things easier or harder Alibaba is just
a tremendous company and they've been a
tremendous asset
overall for for our shareholders and you
know we were very supportive of Jack and
and Joe and and the whole team at
Alibaba they're a big part of our story
and we're a big part of their story you
had said at one point that if you had
three more years so in total seven years
that you could turn this company around
that you could do what you accomplished
to do do you think you could have done
more if you had more time I think that
we see the path to growth that said I do
think that path gets accelerated with
Verizon and that's something I'm very
excited about so I do think that we will
get Yahoo back to growth on the revenue
side we've obviously continually grown
on the user side our user base is up by
about 50 percent over the past four
years with that mobile base tripling and
so we've had user growth throughout they
we've had a large legacy business that's
been declining and so I'm incredibly
proud of the growth that we've had we
took mobile video native and social we
identified those early and grew them to
one point six billion dollars in revenue
from basically nothing in 2011 and I'm
incredibly proud of that I do think that
we would we will and we'll keep in
either scenario the mavens growing and
I'm just overall excited about the fact
that I think that Verizon is a great
acceleration to that effort again I'm
here with Yahoo CEO Marissa Mayer thanks
to all of you on radio for listening is
there anything that you would have done
differently even one thing when you look
back on the last four years I think
overall when I think about things I
prefer to be more focused on the future
and the opportunities and you know
certainly you know there are things that
if you knew more of the back story
behind why they happened or how they
happened they may be more or less harder
easier to understand but I think overall
you know all those experiences are what
makes us who we are and you know I'm
really proud of the team here and I'm
proud of the accomplishments there's
always you know there's always going to
be a bit of a mix but on the whole it's
a great day for the company and a great
outcome so beyond the immediate future
in the next phase what do you really
want to do next will you be a public
company CEO again I know you love
product would you want to be a VC do you
want to start something of your own
like what interests you I love being
involved with companies get they get the
privilege of changing the world
and I got that at Google I got that here
again at Yahoo and and you know I love
all phases of companies you know I was a
Google from tens hundreds thousands tens
of thousands I managed you know you know
Singleton's that tens now hundreds
thousands you and I love all phases of
of companies I've I've loved you know
the the the effort and the energy and
the hard work required to try and stem a
decline that we've had here at Yahoo by
replacing with new business and so you
know all of that is is overall really
really exciting to me but it's really
about that that rare privilege of being
able to be part of a company that gets
to transform transform culture and
transform people's lives you had three
children in this job you became a mom
you know your decisions around parenting
were highly scrutinized for whatever
it's worth but how has I mean that's
such a big accomplishment like how has
motherhood changed you and change the
way that you lead and your approach to
business I think that you know you
learned so much about yourself and
having children and you know my children
are just amazing you know there it is
motherhood's an incredible experience
overall but you learn a lot about
yourself and like I learned that I know
I have my quality time with my kids but
I love to work I love to have an impact
I love to talk with them you know
overall about it my my my parents are
visiting this week and they had to laugh
because because you know yesterday my
son came up we were making plans for
dinner and he said okay so you're going
to go and you're going to do your board
call and that I'm going to go and kick
the ball and then we'll have dinner like
okay and so my parents just laughing so
silly that my three and a half year old
knows what a board call is but you know
but it's been something that you know to
me it's been a very much a blended
lifestyle where you know I get my
quality time with them and watching them
grow and learn you know my my background
was you know artificial intelligence and
symbolic systems Stanford which is
basically how people learn so to watch
your own children learn it's just it's
just incredible but it's also what I've
learned about myself is I love to work I
love to have a big impact I love to have
that base to grow on
to to bond with them over and for me
it's really important to keep going you
know I think that just being able to
come up with a blended working style
that that incorporates them but still
allows me to prioritizes has been
important